they say he always remember your true
love and I remember mine it lasted about
two months and he was really hectic I
like to see this I bumped into her but
she bumped into me so hard that I always
hit the ambulance and he had two bodies
that day but thankfully thankfully he
would didn't happen so after that she
bought me a cup of coffee and after that
we had we had one more date and from
then on we had our honeymoon period you
know the first month that's a honeymoon
period and probably the most fun I've
ever had in my life we wake up with put
pepper spray in our eyes just for the
kicks of it we'd draw boobs and other
stuff on our faces when we were asleep
and either maybe other people don't find
that funny but I found that funny she
found that funny which is why we were
together for such a nice period of time
but then after that first one happened
but something disconnected between us
I'm not sure what I didn't really like
drinking as much she didn't really go
like go out so after a month and a half
we had a nice chatting we told ourselves
well one of us has to go out or one of
us has to go down or would you like to
do she looked at me and gave me a smile
like properly and I smile next thing I
know I go out by myself I get drunk I
come back I don't know what happened
between me coming back and the next
morning but I saw some girl on the floor
I saw knife in my hand I saw her body
somewhere and I just kept thinking
well at least I have the knife phone
with me all the time